[Music]
2016 is almost over which means it's
time once again for gamespot's global
team of editors to gather together drop
all pretense of civility and debate
argue and decide what the best games of
the year should be and just like last
year we're presenting you with our
choice of the top 25 games of the last
12 months in ranked order from 25 all
the way to our game of the year our list
of the best 25 games is a reflection of
the gamespot hive mind a combination of
a wide array of peace experiences and
preferences of dozens of GameSpot
editors from around the world it's a
varied list where you'll find some of
the biggest and most bombastic shooters
of the year they'll be standing
alongside smaller independently made
games and all while flanked by a wide
range of other eclectic genres Oh
finally and it's not just games either
for the first time ever we're presenting
our picks for top movies TV shows and
comic books of 2016 games are still our
key focus but we're expanding to a wider
universe of entertainment to help you
decide the best use of your non-gaming
time so how do we come up with this
games list it all starts with our
editors video producers and
personalities from our offices around
the world that's right we all meet up
and we canvassed our personal picks for
the whole year mash it all together into
a bigger more comprehensive list and
then we present that list back to the
group from there our editorial team
spends hours upon hours debating the
merits of each game to check its
worthiness for inclusion and that's just
the start from there it's the hard task
of ranking each game and that's a whole
another headache if you're only
interested in what the best games are
for your platform don't worry about it
we got that will also be identifying the
five best games available for each major
platform and we've added a brand new
category for VR enabled games you know
because VR was a thing this year but if
you're passionate gamer and you want to
know what the best experiences are
across all of gaming then gamespot's 25
best games of 2016 is for you think of
the platform nominees as your guide as
to what's the best
for your system while the overall ranked
25 best games of 2016 list tells you
what order you could play them in so
join us over the next few weeks as we
unveil our picks for the top games of
the year you'll agree with some of our
choices and you'll probably disagree
with a lot of them and that's okay
that's really half the fun of all these
things please let us know in the
comments or on Twitter or on Facebook
what you think we got right and what you
would have picked
you